foreign
it's been a World Cup breaking new
ground
[Applause]
[Music]
putting the Middle East in the global
sporting Spotlight by staging football's
biggest event for the first time
everyone who has contributed
to make this world cup the best World
Cup ever what has been achieved here in
the Middle East by welcoming the world
has been quite quite unique there is no
other event which welcomes so many
people the winner
to organize
the 222 FIFA World Cup is Qatar
memory speed from Qatar hope will linger
away from years of scandals
FIFA did change creating a human rights
Advisory board but the independent group
of experts unions and sponsors was
disbanded two years ago Sky News can
reveal it told FIFA there was an urgent
need for a body still providing
independent evaluation of Qatar but it
didn't happen it's quite clear that
since the abolition of the human rights
organization that it had advising of the
committee that it had advising of
internal view there hasn't been a level
scrutiny that they could have been
and external people can offer insights
suggestions ideas as to how human rights
due diligence mitigations and other
aspects of Human Rights work can be
incorporated into a tournament like this
this is the culmination of a 12-year
Journey for FIFA and Qatar with more
than 100 billion pounds spent to deliver
a month-long Festival of football that
did unite an often divided region but
the Legacy will be questioned and the
need for so many of our stadiums that
could fit the entire population of
qataris and the suffering of Migrant
workers despite improved conditions will
forever cast a shadow over this most
controversial of World Cups
for some it will forever be a World Cup
of exploitation and discrimination how
transformative it has been for Qatar and
the Arab world will be judged long after
Argentina or France are crowned
Champions on Sunday Rob Harris Sky News
Doha